dire
le propriétaire
esprit de combat moral dans le nôtre
personnel militaire
à un niveau élevé maintenant mais tout le monde veut
visiter leurs maisons pour voir les leurs
parents
A mon avis, ils le sont plus avec une femme
ouvrir et vous dire où
secrètement ils ne peuvent pas
répondre
un homme est mieux même pour ses proches
parler à un étranger que le sien
Bien sûr, il m'est difficile de passer à côté de tout cela
à travers moi
puis après la conversation
Bien sûr, mon état est dépressif et
il faut en quelque sorte s'en sortir
dur un peu
Difficile pour
personnel c'est dur de penser Parfois tout
en position
chaque visite ici, il est difficile de penser quoi
était Pour que quelqu'un ne tombe pas pour moins de 200